شرائح توضع في مخ البشر امر لطالم شهدناه
في افلام الخيال العلمي وقد يصبح حقيقه
وواقعا قريبا جدا الى الماسك على قبل عده
ايام على بدء التجارب على البشر في غضون
سته اشهر باستخدام اداه لاسلكيه تطورها
شركات نيورا لينك المتخصصه في صنع شرائح
المخ الموضوع اثار الجدل بين الناس
والشكوك والمخاوف بين المختصين فشركه
نيورا لينك التي تقوم بتطوير وصلات
تاريخيه للمخ بهدف منح المرضى المصابين في
اعاقه القدره عن الحركه والتواصل من جديد
لديها تاريخ في التخلف عن الجدول الزمني
كما ان اليوراني كانت لديها خلافات بشان
تجاربها على القرود التي اجرتها في
الاعوام القليله الماضيه بعد ان اظهرت
السجلات تسببها في التهابات المزمنه ونبات
صراحه
قبل ان يتم قتلها في
[موسيقى]
نهايه
هل بالفعل هكذا شرائح يمكن ان تعيد الحركه
للمصابين بالشلل ويمكن ان تعيد الابصار
للمصابين بفقدان رؤيه طبيه
في احتمال بس الاشياء اللي ما حد يذكر
عنها ان ان هذه عمليه عمليه مخ ما هي
بسيطه
ايفون 1 كل واحد وايفون 14 اسرع
اه لان مضاعفات مثل حاله صرعه سكته دماغيه
نزيه
وبعد يعني كل واحد يبغى يركز على ايجابيات
المشروع هذا
السواء على حيوانات وما ندري عدد
الحيوانات اللي ماتوا مخ الانسان مو سياره
معينه هذه قاعدين نتكلم عن خلايا الجسم
همم ما اعتقد انه راح يقدر يعني يقدر
تجارب في على الانسان خلال سته اشهر هل في
المستقبل يمكن بس حاليا مع المعلومات اللي
عنا من الشركه هذا